hey val how are you doing
oh you're muted
hi um here you go
mexico i i wanted to ask you um i've
been with my eye we've been married for
about 10 years
we just recently um
split
because he wasn't acting as an alpha
male though he looks like one
he sort of like acts like one but but um
he just
got too lazy in the relationship
and when i started working he started
like um he wasn't doing well in his
business so i had to help him out
and he wasn't uh paying me back and that
i sort of resented that
so um
i was wondering how can i help me
uh become the alpha male that i need
how many times
yeah so
you know many times i've had women that
have said how do i get my beta ass
husband boyfriend fiance to become an
alpha
i want to be attracted to again without
without him knowing that i'm getting him
to do it
and the answer is you can't
so she's he can't he he's he's he's he's
chosen that path right i mean if a guy
doesn't want to chase excellence if he
wants to be lazy if he doesn't want to
make money if he lets himself go
then
what are your options you know you're
gonna have a conversation with him and
say look you know when we met each like
you know for example like i've got
standards right and if i was with a
woman and she put on too much weight i'd
be like look when i signed up for this
relationship you're a buck 20. now
you're 160 pounds i don't like this
weight this is not something that i'm
attracted to that's just my preference
if that's what it is that you want to
live life in then i'm sure there's a guy
that likes that we can just part ways
right that's like i wouldn't make a big
deal out of it i'm not going to say go
to the gym strap her on a treadmill or
anything like that that's just my
standard because i look at women as
beauty objects as most guys do right so
women look at guys as what success
objects and because hypergamist you
don't want to look across and down it
sounds like you're doing better than him
right now you make more money
um well sometimes yeah yeah so you're
looking across at this guy right
sometimes down sometimes across and that
doesn't satisfy your hypergamy you want
to look across and up at a guy you want
to look at a guy that's successful that
can lead that's strong that's virtuous
that's competent that can solve problems
right we already have two children
together
how old are they
uh eight and four
okay so what are you going to do now
you're going to leave him
we already spit
i mean we're like
friends now
well
it's it's always better for children if
you want to put the kids interest first
it's always better for kids for them to
have access to both parents as much as
possible so if you're staying together
that's better for the kids if you decide
to part ways it's better for the kids to
have access to both parents 50 50. the
big mistake that most parents make when
they get divorced is one parent's like
i'm more important so i'm going to have
the kids 80 90 of the time
and you can see them on every other
weekend
right and that's the worst thing you you
know that you can do for children so
parents out there if you give a [ __ ]
about your kids make sure that you
either stay together raise them or if
you're going to split up share custody
50 50. um
that's
that's just the facts of life
so there's no way i can help him get and
get to offline well he's got to want it
right i mean like he's got to want it
bad enough and if he doesn't want it and
if he doesn't want to change like you
can't you can lead a horse to water you
can't make him drink right
if he if he doesn't see a reason to do
it if he doesn't see a reason to stay in
the relationship then he's just going to
say well what do you want me to do like
what does he say when you
raise your concerns to him right now
well um before splitting we sort of like
talked about it uh for
for a year almost um he's also like 16
years my senior so he had a previous uh
relationship that ended up in uh divorce
he had uh previously
i'm 35 and
so he's 50 then
yeah
and he's mexican
we're both mexican yeah and you've got a
little bit of an english accent did you
live in the uk
the uk yeah okay and where do you live
now
mexico and
what does mexican law say for divorce
well i mean it's very ambiguous i mean
we can um
share custody if we want i mean it's
just really up to us because there's uh
this like friend divorce that you can do
yeah so
why is he getting lazy like why is he
just uh not that guy anymore
he was never um
very well off
but he always like um behaved by canava
he
he was a a boxer he um
[Music]
he's um muscular and very masculine
but
he was always um
in debt because of uh i guess his
previous family to pay for university
and all that
and that um
well i've only started working like um
three years ago i guess
and i started
well
and so he had a very bad business in
which i had to help him out
how was he when you met him
he was 42 i think okay so he was a
retired boxer was he a successful boxer
no he he did it uh for for pleasure i
mean that's that's not um he works in a
um
metal work he does um metal work okay
and
has like i mean like the thing that
happens to guys is they get older over
40 as they go through andropause and
their testosterone levels drop like is
he getting fat is he getting lazy lack
of drive lack of motivation not
interested in sex
he just he did say that
he wanted to he had cancer before he
said hey i had a previous marriage i had
cancer i nearly died i lived through all
this i just want to live for myself
and so okay let's see what you're saying
well i mean like here's the thing like
what does he say when you talk about the
kids
is he just saying take them and do
whatever you want or is he interested in
being a parent or where's his head at
no he's not he's not really involved
i mean
usually
he was just like laying at home watching
telly and so it's not okay so he's
become lazy
did did he go through the betatization
process did you read my book by the way
i've only came across with you a few
weeks ago right so
so i talk about so it could be a couple
of things so i talk about the beta
tization process which is essentially
men making continuous concessions to
women and this is going to be hard for
you to understand because
um
women don't even know that they do it
right like it starts with something like
you move in together and then you start
changing his habits and his behaviors
don't brush your teeth over there brush
it in the bathroom of the tile it's
going to get on the carpet put your
white socks in the white hammer put your
black socks in the black hyper you can't
eat like this you can't drink like this
you have to do that and the other thing
this is
an alpha because he does all that kind
of like manly stuff like so he does
whatever he wants still yeah
still brings a lot uh goes up with
friends a lot and
but he's but he's not interested in
being a father he's not interested in
being married to you
he's not interested in intimacy he's not
interested in sex with you he's
interested in intimacy i mean we never
had a problem with sex um
just um
just like recently maybe like two three
years ago uh he started like
not too much uh making an effort
it
it could be low t it could be low t for
him right i mean like testosterone is
the male hormone that that drives
motivation desire success risk taking
all that stuff
he did have a vasectomy
okay well a vasectomy is not going to
change his
testosterone levels it just stops sperm
from leaving the nut sac right his
his testicles will still make
testosterone the thing is though as guys
get older the levels drop and if he's
deficient
a lot of the stuff that you're talking
about are symptoms from the deficiency
so he might want to talk to a doctor
about you know checking his hormone
panel his cholesterol panel everything
to see if there's something wrong with
the way that he's living his life his
lifestyle choices that are making him
lazy slow fat you know not interested in
being a parent not interested in being
part of any of this right now and just
kind of like watching tv that's a lot of
guys do when they get older they'll come
home pop open the beer hand down the
pants sit back open up a bag of chips it
falls all over their shirt you know they
make a mess and they just sit there all
night right and
you know that lack of motivation
can be any number of things but for a
lot of guys it just happens to be low t
right
and
you're lucky because you're in mexico so
testosterone is very cheap down there
right like you can go to pharmacy get it
over the counter it's peanuts you don't
even need a prescription
okay
so have them so have them look into his
blood work but again
it's a very difficult conversation for
you to say hey
i want to be in a relationship with you
but you're not the kind of guy that i
want to be with and
you're not happy i'm not happy
right
the only ones that are going to suffer
here is the four and eight year old
because they're not going to have a
proper
parental unit raising them correctly and
that's why a lot of the world is [ __ ]
today is because
you know there's a lot of kids that are
raised in a single parent household and
they miss generally the masculine energy
from their upbringing
it feels like
it feels like it yeah so that's so
that's potentially it
right so i mean like you can have the
conversation with him but is he gonna do
anything about it you know as a thing is
he is he actually motivated right
because a lot of guys when you have this
conversation they're just like oh stop
nagging me again woman i don't want to
hear it right
but it's going to be difficult for you
val because you're you're how old now
you're 34 you said
35. you're 35 you've got two small
children
and what are you gonna do you're gonna
try to find somebody to go and replace
him that's yes um and that's what i
thought i could do but then i came
across with your channel and i thought
it might be a bit more difficult than i
thought so i might as well just try to
fix this first
well if you can fix it that would be
best for the kids probably for sure it's
it's it's more than likely going to be
better for you too because a lot of
women think that the
like the grass is greener on the other
side of the fence and they go out on the
dating market in their mid-30s with a
couple small children in tow and they
realize
guys don't want anything to do with them
i mean
high-value alpha men don't want anything
to do with a single mom with two kids in
tow from a prior relationship they just
don't because they have better options
they can date younger women without kids
make sense
good um
sorry say that again you broke up on my
end i couldn't hear you
should i just uh buy testosterone for
him then uh no he's he's got to want to
do it well you just can't buy it and ask
him to start injecting the stuff like he
has to get proper blood work done
so
i don't know maybe there's like a video
you can find on youtube or something
that you can send them like you know
male testosterone therapy hormone
therapy and just be like hey you know or
i was talking to my girlfriend and her
husband was dealing with these symptoms
and he had his blood work check and like
have you had your blood work checked you
know there could be something wrong with
you i love the kids i know you love the
kids i want to do what's right for the
kids but we can't live like this you
know you like
have a conversation with a dude right
okay well thank you all right all right
belle see you hey guys i really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you